franksen ohio hey Frank how are you hey
Dave I'm doing well how are you better
than I deserve what's up awesome hey so
I've got kind of a more of a moral
question here so I recently graduated
college I've been out for about a year
and a half I've been working with a
great paying job living at my parents
house they were nice enough to let me
come back home and save up some money
trying to reach my goal of putting 20%
down on a house within the next three to
five years out of college and they've
given me the gift of my college
education all of my loans that they're
paying for all the things associated
with college as well I've kind of built
myself a nice best egg and my question
is should I step up to the plate and
offer to take on the student loans for
them in my name
okay so the student loans are in your
name or they're in their name they're in
my name but the payments are made by my
parents and how much student loan debt
do you have in your name if I had I
don't know the exact number if I had to
guess it's probably somewhere in the
neighborhood of 40 to $50,000 and what
do you make of your sir a little over
seventy thousand and what's your nest
egg built up to I've got twenty thousand
in my 401k thirteen thousand in a Roth
IRA thirty-two thousand a brokerage
account mix of mutual funds and stocks
and then two K's an emergency fund
okay I don't know if it's a moral
question or not in my mind it might be
expediency but I here's the thing if
your parents for any possible reason
they lost their health they died in a
car wreck
they lost their business they lost their
jobs whatever they got sued by somebody
for half a million dollars and took
their income away I don't know for any
possible reason it would
probably be a fairly bizarre reason all
of those examples are fairly bizarre but
if if they do these are your loans if
they simply don't pay them on time
because they're disorganized they these
are your loans they're gonna damage your
credit not theirs
right and so as a matter of practicality
and expediency and it has the nice
byproduct of getting the weight off of
them I'd clean out that brokerage
account and pay off these student loans
okay that's what I would do okay and
then and then I'd get me an apartment
start saving money and get out on your
own and start saving money for a house
again because you've done a great job of
building this up and I stopped your 401k
until you're out of debt have an
emergency fund and stop building up
brokerage accounts and stop building up
all this stuff until you do you're out
of debt and have an emergency fund clear
up any debts that are in your name now
if they took out Parent PLUS loans that
are in their name that's a different
issue
you did not promise to pay them and they
promised to pay them and they want to
pay them then I'd let them pay but the
loans that are in your name might knock
them out